hello everyone and welcome back to day
two of the Magnus Invitational we're
still at round one and it's an opponent
versus Fabiana Caruana both of the
members of the the 2020 candidates
tournament which was so abruptly
adjourned and like I said this is Game
two of their match but game 1 game was
very interesting but it then ended in
has drawn young one for his French
defense which he also used in the
candidates tournament still deciding on
whether or not show that once but I was
at the skip to game 2 as it features a
most interesting move so without further
ado let's check it out young with the
with the white pieces opens with E 4 and
the father goes again for his e5 as he
did in the candidates he's playing or
obviously BDR congas variation of the
rule opus Bishop to b5 we have the rule
opus on the board a six more fees
defense Bishop day for a ninth day f6
we have castles b5 Bishop to b3 and now
this Bishop to c5 at the modern are
congas instead of Bishop to b7 with a
four white usually will challenge blacks
Queen side points with this with this
push with Bishop to be 7 and now b3
strengthening the center preparing to
develop the dark square Bishop as well
castles by Fabi and Bishop to g5 now
with h6 challenging the bush a bush up
to h4 and bush of the back to e7 now not
not really enjoying this pin and here we
have a couple of characters characters
captors with characters here queen
capture sunday 8 and now comes night to
a3 here
there are some games in the database
were Bishop to g3 and the nice the c3
was played but Nippo prepared something
wild for Fabi here night the a3 and it
is as a move 13 that we have a
completely new game so what's the idea
well it attacks the b5 one sin same as
the knight from c3 however here neppo is
actually preparing c4 and he doesn't
want to block his upon wit with Knight
to c3
far be defensive with Queen to a5 and
now that Bishop to d5
before pushing c4 we have these six by
favi and now see for now preparing to
meet before with night - see - and then
you can shift the night over for example
to e3 and then to f5 which will be an
excellent square for the night however
after see for Bobby captures be cappers
and c4 we have Queen tonight captors
attacking the Queen and the Queen to b5
now and now Knights the e3 right away
and now from here the knight can again
come to fi or maybe g4 in the future we
have Bishop the c8 preventing Knight to
f5 and now that nipple goes for Bishop
captures on f6 removes this tension on
the bishop we have Bishop captures and
now Queen to c2 adding a second attacker
to the night here and also preparing to
bring the rook into the game we have
Bishop to d7 defending and now rook to
a1 just bringing the rook nicely to D to
the D only open file on the board we
looked the b8 now putting pressure on
the b2 pawn and Napo defends that would
be three and it's a it's it's a very
interesting position especially since
nipple a seed is prepared that night
they remove probably had these positions
on the board and it's hard to say
yeah if Bobby had positions that arise
after night to a three on the board at
home so push back the d8 now the knight
can move as the c7 pawn will be
protected and now Russia back to C for
attacking the Queen clearing the d5
square for the knight we have Queen to
c5 and now comes h3 just taking away the
g4 square from blacks pieces but also at
some point at the night might come to g4
we have Knights the before attacking
their post Queen putting pressure on the
e3 pawn and the Queen to d1 now
and now c6 here fob is ready to strike
in the center with d5 but look the c1 by
nipple now preparing Bishop captures on
f7 check to win the Queen on c5 so Queen
back to a7 and now nipple strikes in the
center first with the d4
we have a captures on d4 Knight captures
on d4 and now Bishop to f6 with a double
attack on the night here and now Knight
back to f3
nipple doesn't like night at five
it just trades down pretty much
everything after d5 you would get
characters captures Bishop captures you
cannot capture with the night because
then then the night Hank so Bishop
captures night captures Queen captures
and of course now Bishop to e6 you go
back after after your phone you're down
upon so he went to wind it back and
Blackwood just have two bishops against
two knights so would be will be
definitely interesting if in anything
else for black so after Bishop f6 neppo
doesn't like Knight to a5 he goes back
Knight to f3 and Queen to c7 now we have
Queen to d2 again putting pressure on
the knight and c5 now defending gets on
out the rook can also join the game we
work the d1 putting pressure on the d6
pawn and here bash up the c6 just
offering that one for the e4 pawn which
neppo declines he goes Knight to g4
instead and he says ok I'm offering d4
pawn for Knight captures on f6 are you
willing to ruin your pawn structure for
that
efore pawn and interestingly Fabi is
willing to do it Bishop to e7 you could
play that just get the bishop out of
harm's way also defend the d6 pawn one
more time
but Fabi actually captures on e4 and now
comes the moment we've been waiting for
Knight characters on f6 with check G
captures in the Queen to f4 now putting
pressure on the bishop and also the f6
pawn and here best for nip best for Fabi
is Bishop captures on f3 and after G
captures then you want to move the King
you bring the rook over here but black
can do the same you can move the King
and then bring the rook into the game so
it would be very interesting however
probably played Bishop to g6 here and
the Bishop to g6 loses the game terribly
so feel free to find this post video and
try to find this a winning idea for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds so I mean amazing as it is for
those of you who were able to do it the
correct move is Knight to h4 for those
of you who just wanna enjoy the show it
does seem weird that such a move is just
winning 4/4 nepo but the problem is
there's the obvious threat of Knight
actress because you will not be able to
recapture due to this pin here so you
might you might have some ideas on how
to defend for example if King to h7 then
rook captures on d6 and now you have
problems because after rook to b6
challenging the rook twice now again if
route capture if Queen captures you can
just pick up the rook here the problem
is Knight to f5 and this is the move
that was incredibly hard to find and
here you have you have some interesting
choices but none of them none of them
actually work for example if you if if
you decide to grab the knight then just
Queen captures on f5 with check King to
g8 and then now Queen to g6 with check
or if King went to g7 then you just
capture here with the check so King the
faith Queen captures with the check King
to yet you would go Quinta h8 with check
King e7 and now finally Queen captures
on f6 with check King here and now you
win the Queen or rather after Queen
captures as there are no other moves
Queen has the capture and now just Queen
captures on f7 with mate so this is what
happens after Knight f5 if Bishop
captures and like I said this is why I
decided to show this game as it's really
just a monster move and if you don't
capture the night you could try
something like King to g8 it seems like
it solves all of your problems but not
really because here why it has Bishop
captures on f7 and here amazingly you
could capture with the bish of the king
or the Queen and all the moves lose for
example if Bishop captures then you just
run into a meeting a meeting net with
Queen to g4 check King to f8 and now
Queen to g7 check King t8 and now a nice
queen to h8 followed by there are no
moves the rock covers D squares night
covers e7 the King has no squares you
have to block with the bishop and Queen
captures and g8 is checkmate
so that's what happens if you capture
with the bishop if you capture with the
Queen
well then it's just the very ugly rook
to d8 trick and since the night covers
g7 you can only give up the Queen or
move to the H file which will be
followed of course by Queen to h6 o
quintet Queen to h6 checkmate
so not much not much to do there and
lastly of course but not leastly if you
don't capture with the bishop or with
the Queen you could capture with the
King but then the problem is you allow
this group to move with check with
deadly purpose and then of course it's
just rook captures nf6 shirt and you
pick up the Queen here King characters
you pick up the Queen you attack the
rook and 95 defends the rook attacks the
Queen but now Queen d8 check now if you
capture here just Queen captures night
so you might defend but still India and
it all it works out for white 93 yeah
you cannot move the knight because then
just Queen captures rook and if rook b6
then we have Quinta CA to check and
after the King finally moves anywhere
you grab on c5 and now again there's a
double attack on the night and also
attack on the rook so completely winning
for white so incredible but fabi's
Bishop to g6 loses the game terribly
tonight to h4 however nepo doesn't play
it he plays rook captures on d6 and now
it is similar to the night h4 idea but
now rugby six actually defense for Fabi
because you don't have that in-between
move that we mentioned and now you you
don't really have the option now the
only way to seek advantage would be to
go for Queen captures on h6 sacrifice
the rook but it doesn't work Queen
captures here with check King f8 Queen
h6 check King to e7 and now you could go
for Quinta III check because you have to
you have to be careful rugby wanna check
with with the Queen covering h2 it's
game over
so Queen III check and after let's say
King d8 you can make some breathing room
for the king but still you are down the
exchange you don't have a past each pawn
so it's not all that bleak but the black
should definitely be better
so after would be six never decided just
the trade route characters on f6 we have
Queen captures on f4 and now rook
captures on f4 and now we have the same
game where Nippo is still better he's up
upon but it's not going to be easy
Knights to d3 attacking the rook we have
worked the g4 now preparing h4 and h5 to
maybe win the bishop nice to be to and
now Knight to e5 now with a double
attack on the bishop also defending
the bishop here preparing to recapture
with the pawn so Knight captures pawn
captures and the King to g7 now just
helping out with the defense with H for
preparing Age 5 but first rook the e6
pushing net was night back Knight to d7
and now h5 not allowing in able to push
h5m self rooked f4 and now comes Luke
the c6 just defending that c5 pawn
Knight to e5 and now rook to d6 and
getting the rock out of harm's way we
have Knight captures on g6 King captures
and rook to e4 and we reach this row
component game where nipple is still up
upon but like I said it's it's not easy
to convert a upon up in the inner box
endgame or sometimes it's even
impossible so Rudy one check King H to
look to see one now just putting in the
room behind the pond and King g3 we rook
to c2 now the rocker is putting pressure
on a lot of white pawns and the King to
f3 with King to f5 and now rook F for
check King g6 we have g4 and now rook
the c3 check King to e2 h captures rook
captures with check and the King h5 just
going after the pawn rook not there rook
the f4 going after the f7 pawn and now
comes King to g6 just defending with
King to d2 and now look back to h3 we
have looked the g4 check King f5 and
rook the g4 a g5 check King to e4 and
now we have a nice straight of pawns
rook captures on c5 rook captures on h4
and rook to d5 and now an fo did create
a passed C pawn and he will of course
try to push it
rook h3 and now king - C - we'll work
the f3 going after the f2 pawn and now
rook the d2 defending and also cutting
off the black King from reaching the
white pawn so King e5 and now King to d1
we have Quinta east 6 and now rook to c2
of course you have to put your look
behind the past pawn king to d6 and King
to eat you now so slowly but surely
making progress we've cooked a 3 and now
f3 by nipple King to c5 blocking the
pawn and our King to f2
rook to d3 and now look the c1 rook the
d4 going after the pawn here and the
Kings to e3 and here f5 just advancing
the pawn a little bit further we have f4
and now here fog we just played rook
captures on c4 and it was in this
position that they agreed to a draw as
it is in fact a draw and if you're
interested why it's a draw because after
the rooks are traded AUP there's no way
to do anything about this white cannot
cross across this a de for nd for
squares and the black will not it's
irrelevant for black because even if
black wins the point it's still a draw
for example King it to King before
you're gonna play King to f3 King d3 and
now we're likely to have a repetition
here or like I said you can even give up
give up on King III air King g2 captures
and now you grab your position and of
course it's still a draw and for those
of you if for some reason still don't
believe it's a draw after King before
you go king he to f4 came to f2 with f3
now King the f1 not II won of course
King the III now again you grab your
position after checking f1 and king of
three and it's a drop by stalemate and
if this is this comes as news to you
then you should usually definitely start
with some endgame lessons so now after
rook captures and c4 they agree to a row
of course and wild game so really it's a
game that could have had a lot of impact
on the match and well and the reason why
probably in my opinion why neppo missed
the Knights to h4 idea he didn't spend
too much time in the position and he
didn't expect there to be such such a
tricky win against a player of Bobby's
caliber Rob idea like I always say it's
just anything can happen and here it
didn't happen sure that's a Game two of
their match I do hope you enjoyed it
really really a wild game I would like
to thank cut-up Prendergast for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday